decoders welcome to the daily program or
YouTube series where we solve different
problems posted on the subreddit daily
programmer
in this particular video we're going to
talk about a problem called condensing
sentences which is number three one nine
on the subreddit and first off before we
start talking about the problem make
sure you spend time yourself solving on
paper and implementing and JavaScript so
that you really practice by yourself how
to problem solve otherwise let's go
ahead and break it down on the
whiteboard all right so the condensing
sentences problem is like so it's given
a string for instance we have a string
has no one ever runs so often what we
want to do is condense the words
together so if there's any overlap so in
this case we have oh so the oh is
overlap we should combine them together
into one word and then again if this one
will overlap with the next one we need
to combine it with the next word or our
overlaps here s overlaps with that and
then often again it's another overlap so
in this case we're going to convert this
entire sentence into one combined string
now another example we can do is live
vs. which is going to be condensed into
live RF es so notice that there's two
here that overlap and then we only use
that once so then if we have a string
such as hello world this would have no
convincing happening to it because the
beginning of the right word does not
have anything that matches at the end of
the left word so now that we talked
about the problem and how it's actually
defined how would we actually solve this
on paper right so if we have another
word so let's go and put the string
again live versus if we wanted to check
if two words in this case I'll say this
is the left word and this is the right
word if I want to check if the light the
left word and the right word should be
combined what I can do is just
continuously look through the left word
and shorten the word that I'm looking
for from the starting point so for
instance I can say
does live our live exists at the
beginning of the right word if not check
the next one this idea exists indicating
of the right word and in this case it
doesn't so then again check if ve begins
the ending of the right word and it does
so in this case we know we can condense
these words together and we can do so
continue on to the next words in the
string so there's two main sub problems
that you can solve in order to solve the
major problem this first one is given
two strings can you convince them
together and if so how do you convince
them together right and we just show
that used continuously create sub
strings by knocking off the first
character the left and checking if it
exists at the start of the right all
right so for solving the second sub
problem assume we have a longer string
how do we make sure we loop over every
word and condense where possible all
right so one thing you can do is first
we can break this apart by spaces right
and convert it into some type of an
array or list so instead of being an
actual string we can instead just say
that we have an internal array with our
four words in it and over here we have
the different indexes of that array so
the first step to do was to take the
left word so let's say left and I'll say
right
and check if they can be condensed and
if they can be condensed what you want
to do is combine them together and
overwrite this slot and the array with
the condensed worth so remember the
array of index 0 we put the condense
word into and then the index 1 word we
can just go ahead and remove because we
already combined it with the previous
one and if you remove something from
array remember that the indices get
updated so then we can continue to do
the same thing and since we just found
and condensed a word let's keep this on
the same so left but now we're just
checking a new right word so can these
to be condensed no they cannot so at
this point what we can continuously do
is just change the left and the right or
increment or loop so now we have this as
our left word and this as a right word
and then again that we cannot combine
these or condenses together so at this
point we've reached the end of the array
so we can go ahead and break out of the
the loop so at this point you should
have a good understanding of how to do
this on a whiteboard or on paper so
let's try to convert it and implement it
in JavaScript so like we mentioned
before there's two sub problems you can
solve in order to solve the overall top
level problem so the first sub problem
is how do you condense two words
together and find out if they should be
condensed at all so to start off let's
write a function called condense words
and it takes two parameters a left and a
right which is a left word and the right
word and then that's going to return
null if they can't condense the words
otherwise it's going to return the two
words convinced together so starting off
remember that algorithm we did where we
have to loop through each substring and
kind of chunk offs at the first letter
of the left word so to do that we can go
ahead and loop through the length of the
left word
and we can say left substring is equal
to less done substring of that I which
will go ahead and say give us all the
characters and then give us all the
characters starting index 1 give us all
the characters starting index 2 until we
get to the very last character and once
we have the left stroke of substring we
can check to say does the right start
with things actually called starts with
so does write that starts with left
substring and if it does let's just go
ahead and return that condensed word
which is going to be left plus the right
and then replace that left substring
with an empty string and then up here
and secure the extra space and then we
can go ahead and try to test it out to
make sure it works as expected so I'll
do console dot log and I'll pass it live
and I'll pass it vs. and again an
example this should print out one word
combined together so if I were to run
this we see that it does print out the
two words combined so that we've written
our first subproblem to condense two
words together and that we've tested out
to make sure it works let's also test
that with hello world and verify that it
returns null and it does so again this
is a good example of how you solve a
top-level problem by breaking it into
subproblems and testing it as you
develop it so now we know this one's
good so let's work on the other sub
problem which will be condensed sentence
which will take a string and again what
we need to do is loop over that string
for each word and like we saw an example
on the Y for B to split it first so we
can say let words I shall do contours is
equal to string dot split like the type
and we're going to split it on the empty
characters all right so that'll give us
all the words split up and then finally
we want to return those same words but
join together so then the potatoes of
this method is we need to loop over
every word one by one so we'll say
let our sorrow say before let I is equal
to zero I less than fours dot length
minus one and then increment I and
that's because we don't want to actually
reach the end of the string and go out
of bounds so we stop I wanted before the
end and then again we have the left on
the right so we can say constant left is
equal to words of I concentrate is equal
to words of I plus 1 and then we need to
call condense words so we'll say Const
condense is equal to condense words left
and right
if condense is actually defined
therefore we could have convinced the
words together we need to go ahead and
overwrite the first word with the
condensed word go ahead and remove this
two condensed and then we need to remove
index plus one or I plus one so we can
say words that splice I plus 1 and then
length of 1 which will just remove the
next word since we combined it with the
previous one and then finally we need to
continuously check the same word that
we've condensed over and over again to
see if it can be combined with the 1
after so we can say I - - to kind of
prevent it from doing this increment up
here so at this point we can kind of go
up here in fact let's before we do this
let's make this a little bit easier so
just so we have less variables to mess
around once we can say there knesset
equals condense words words I or it's I
plus 1 so now at this point we can
change from condense words to convince
sentence and then we can change this to
like one of those long sentences we had
before which I just copy this in here
no one ever runs so often if we run this
see that it prints out all the words
combined together are condense together
I also have a couple of other ones on my
clipboard we can kind of try out so clay
and paste those in so we see no one has
ever run so often gets combined the one
yellow low dog gets combined two yellow
dog the black kettle is hot we combine
black and kettle together so it's going
to condensed and of course hello world
does not get condensed subtle gold
cybermats wraps up how you solve this
condensed sentences problem number three
one nine on the DV program or subreddit
if you have any questions feel free to
ask them in the comments below or if you
have a different implementation feel
free to post your jsbin or whatever link
that you want and maybe we can have a
discussion about other ways to solve
this I saw one solution which uses regex
to solve this which is like one line of
code but I feel like as a beginner
programmer you should probably learn how
to manually solve things before you just
resort to using regex although rhetorics
is pretty elegant again if you liked the
video feel free to give us a thumbs up
and then also subscribe to the free code
camp channel below alright thanks for
watching